the Joe Rogan experience right right
then you're not worth a hundred million
dollars anymore that's right
how do you go from zero to a hundred
million dollars as you're in Congress
well you're a criminal that's that's
what Truman said yeah there's there's
the only kind of people get rich while
in government are criminals that's what
Truman said but there's like isn't it
something like there's forms of insider
trading that are legal if you're in
Congress that wouldn't be legal if you
were a regular citizen I don't know I
know that they don't have them the rules
that they should write I know that
there's rules that I shouldn't say
regular citizen but if you were like
working for a corporation there's rules
like they're allowed to get information
and influence in terms of like how they
invest all right if that's not right
right that's that's extra information
that I could get exact yeah that's right
extra and then they're allowed to get
that information and then they're
allowed to use it for their own personal
profit like somehow or another that's
not been stomped out yeah and that was
someone there was a video and I don't
know if it's accurate or someone was
explaining how Nancy Pelosi made all
that money and I was like if I watch
this [ __ ] thing I'm gonna stay up all
night it was one of those like I can't
watch any more of this yeah well you
have a hundred million error is the
leader of the People's Party as well
that amazing not only that like what did
you do did you sell hats or did you make
that money what do you do do you make
cars why do you think Nancy Pelosi
impeach Trump I did impeach George Bush
I don't know I'll tell you tell me as
Julian Assange revealed through
WikiLeaks it was because Nancy Pelosi
was told in 2002 that our government was
torturing people and she was a present
person in a position of power and the
reason why the Republicans in George
Bush administration did that was so now
they've got Democrats complicit in their
crimes and so she didn't tell anybody
about it she didn't lost an
investigation she didn't blow the
whistle on this so now she's complicit
so when George Bush lute once when the
Republicans lose the house and she
becomes leader and they go you're gonna
impeach him she goes impeachment off the
table and nobody could figure it out but
nobody pushed her on it because we were
just so glad we had a check on George
Bush at that time well Julian Assange
then reveals there's a there's the memo
that shows that she was briefed in 2002
on their torture program which makes her
complicit and towards her because she
didn't
goddamn think about it did you see the
interview that I did with Edward Snowden
no yeah yeah yeah that's not the first
half it was very interesting yeah Danny
Pelosi came up oh yeah he came up that
she was one of the people that cleared
they made it so that these cell phone
companies have access to your data and
can can spy on you and use it the
government can use cell phones and also
all sorts of telecommunications and
essentially the video your your
voicemail emails all that [ __ ] all that
all that [ __ ] can can get spied through
and there was it was very complicated
like I don't I don't remember the exact
thing that that I don't remember the
exact scam like but Pelosi was involved
in that there you go I mean they're all
corrupt
[Applause]